joining us now pam bondi is with us uh
for commentary as well as fox news legal
analyst greg jarrett pam your take on
all of this
sean having personally as a prosecutor
for 18 years signed thousands of
subpoenas
thousands
many times people don't comply so what
do you do you either issue a new
subpoena or you do a motion to compel
why wasn't that done in this case the
trump people were working well with them
why wasn't that done that's a question
for merrick garland number two for
merrick garland the warrant think about
the warrant if you're going to issue a
warrant the reason has to be i'm worried
they're going to destroy evidence well
what's suspect about that we've now
learned that warrant was signed on
friday but not executed until monday so
why get the warrant that doesn't even
make sense number three i have
personally been involved in
many many search warrants authorizing
them the execution of the search
warrants and they came in there with
guns blazing like you said
for documents you know what you do you
get a couple agents you go up you show
the warren at mar-a-lago they knew the
president wasn't there they knew it was
a skeleton crew at mar-a-lago you go in
you go to the safe you go to the office
you get the documents you need done yet
what did they do
they brought they did an execution on
land on sea by air they had agents in
the water agents in the air you may have
only seen 30 to 40 there on the ground
but there were hundreds of agents that
had to have been weaponized to pull the
assault off at mar-a-lago that day and
that night merrick garland that's where
that's where tax dollars are going to
that did you see the massive trucks out
there sean lined around you know why
they did that it was the optics they
thought donald trump would look like a
common criminal but it backfired on them
and the american people have seen what
they've done and they are disgusted by
this and he's got a lot more explaining
to do
and and you know look at this look look
what they did to peter navarro look at
what they did to manafort look at what
they did to roger stonehill join us
tonight greg this is now their tactic
they want to harass intimidate and send
a message to everyone else don't mess
with us we're all powerful almighty and
the double standard the dual system of
justice couldn't be any more clear than
it is now
yeah i don't question the integrity of
the doj and the fbi i criticize the
utter lack of integrity and rectitude of
merrick garland and christopher wray
eric garland today unwittingly stupidly
undermined his own argument when he said
our standard practices use the least
intrusive method that's called a
subpoena and the fbi did that
two months ago
they were counting on donald trump
challenging it so that they would then
be poised for a raid
but trump capitulated he gave them
everything they wanted so they probably
sat back at the doj and said now what
are we going to do
uh well they should have issued another
subpoena if they wanted more documents i
suspect all of that is left out
of
the affidavit in support of the fbi
warrant to search the premises and i
think they probably snookered this
magistrate who by the way is not a
regular federal district court judge uh
he's appointed by the district court to
do the sort of grunt work uh he doesn't
have the experience a real judge would
have probably said wait a minute
wait a minute
from a case with hillary clinton why
didn't he excuse himself here
well he's in dangerous times his social
media posts were virulently anti-trump
under the law he's required to recuse
himself but a good judge would have said
wait a minute why aren't you using a
subpoena here there are a lot of
questions about this magistrate himself
all right thank you uh pam bondi we
appreciate it greg jarrett thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else